[Music]
many people say Isis is not Islamic
because they have killed more Muslims
than non-muslims Isis has been
criticized for killing Muslims as well
as non-muslims because this is in
apparent Defiance of the quran's
injunction never is it for a Believer to
kill a Believer except by mistake so in
their own defense partisans of the
Islamic State have argued not on
Prudential but on Islamic theological
grounds making copious reference to
Islamic sources they've portrayed the
murderous behavior of the Islamic State
as legitimate Jihad operations that
every Muslim should endorse responding
to similar criticism 10 years ago Iraqi
Jihad leader Abu musab a zar kawi the
leader of the al-Qaeda group that
ultimately became Isis insisted that his
group was behaving in a strictly Islamic
manner he took for granted that Muslims
had a responsibility before Allah to
wage war against unbelievers Zara said
there's no doubt that Allah commanded us
to strike the kufar that is unbelievers
kill them and fight them by all means
necessary to achieve the goal he
emphasized that any means at all were
permissible in this endeavor he said the
Servants of Allah who performed Jihad to
elevate the word of Allah are permitted
to use any and all means necessary to
strike the active unbeliever combatants
for the purpose of Killing Them snatch
their souls from their body cleanse the
Earth from their abomination and lift
their trial and persecution of the
Servants of Allah this goal must be
pursued even if the means to accomplish
it affect both the intended active
Fighters and unintended passive ones
such as women children or any other
passive category specified by our jurist
Prudence aarabi was arguing in other
words that operations such as 9911 were
fully sanctioned by Islamic law even if
women and children were killed in them
and that remained true he argued even if
Muslims were killed as collateral damage
he said this permissibility extends to
situations in which Muslims may get
killed if they happen to be with or near
the intended enemy and if it is not
possible to avoid hitting them or
separate them from the intended cfir
although spilling sacred Muslim blood is
a grave offense it is not only
permissible but it is mandated in order
to prevent more serious adversity from
happening stalling or abandoning Jihad
that
is now zarabi was killed over 2 years
before Barack Obama became president and
eight years before Obama said ISO as he
calls the Islamic state is not Islamic
Obama said no religion condones the
killing of Innocents and the vast
majority of isil's victims have been
Muslim Obama was assuming that because
its victims were Muslim the Islamic
state must not be Islamic however isis's
foremost founding figure had long before
that explained why this was a false
assumption moreover as far as zarabi was
concerned those who denied that it was
permissible to kill Muslims in Jihad
operations were enabling the victory of
the infidels over the Muslims and the
consequent disunity and subjugation of
the worldwide Muslim Community he said
if one says that we must not allow the
killing of Muslims under any
circumstance especially in light of
modern war tactics this means nothing
except stalling or permanently
abandoning Jihad this will lead to
handing over the land and people to the
unbelievers who are full of hate for
Islam and Muslims the unbelievers will
have a free hand to humiliate and
persecute Islam and Muslims and Muslims
will be forced to live by cfir rules and
be treated like slaves many Muslims will
be pressured or forced to give up their
religion Islam will be altered modified
and replaced with another form that will
be totally different from that which was
revealed to the one who was sent with
the sword peace and prayer be upon Him
of course he's referring to Muhammad the
principles zarka delineated would become
the Hallmarks of the Islamic State that
any means were acceptable in fighting
against and killing non-muslims which
was an Islamic responsibility and that
it was acceptable to kill fellow Muslims
in service of the goal of implementing
Islamic law over the entire
world